Marvel's walk back out to the pond test
behind the line wanted to play well out
of the chute it really is a look at
barman as soon as he realizes the double
teams coming a really quick pass out but
about a look he's just waiting for the
double-team just painting in about day
with it
nice easy catch some of the rotations on
that ball it is to clean this fair game
got one when I go home tonight Mavericks
will the Mavericks have second free book
gives the turnover over to the Hornets
timing on this place screen the screener
and that creates confusion remaining
here in our second quarter wrong grade
makes up for a miscue the time before
our score will be back to uptown in just
a moment
[Music]
Nick Batum back on the floor from the
Hornets as a final two minutes of our
ask about the last minute and a half
Hornets can hold for the final shot
answers with a three Keith made five
triple yes cauley-stein opportunities
have a chin up with the rim
that's it a big basket that the score is
indeed 76 to 70s through the Jew that
was at three Perrault's year good news
[Applause]
Hornets have it back Devon tech 7 of 10
yeah just drop it off and Chris has been
in a lot of 19 just a moment ago
[Applause]
all sudden you can't blink games can't
be in games it'll wear you out
mentally
[Applause]
[Music]
the franchise record for three's in a
game a dime piece of threes and they've
all been it's some type of energetic
fashion